збільшити видатки розвитку на підготовку
кадрів у сфері статистики друзі
статистика поважаю важливо все Ну
можливо не під час війни збільшувати ще
ну якісь там вже є видатки ну куди ще
збільшувати на підготовку кадрів в сфері
статистики в нас головна статистика
скільки прикопали кожнй ранок вся країна
дивляться цю статистику давайте
допомагати нашим статистикам зі збройних
сил України статистикам з національної
гвардії
статистикам з ДПСУ статистикам з дсст
ссо тро оце наші
статистики давайте подивимось Зараз я
вам покажу як голосують статистикам
давати гроші статистикам
розумієте і один голос проти друзі один
от 241 проти один Це мій Друзі Ну це
ненормально